bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi au
lendemain de leur face-à-face ségolène
royal et nicolas sarkozy sont repartis
en campagne dernier gros meeting pour la
candidate socialiste à lille aux côtés
notamment de jacques delors et à
montpellier pour le candidat ump
un débat très suivi 20 millions de
personnes étaient devant leur téléviseur
et chaque camp s'attribue la victoire
pour ses partisans nicolas sarkozy a su
rester méthodique et maître de lui pour
la gauche ségolène royal a été solide et
combative
on reviendra en détail sur les changes
le plus vif de cette soirée se couchent
colère de la candidate concernant la
scolarisation des enfants handicapés
le gouvernement parle de contrevérités
qui dit vrai éléments de réponse dans un
instant les adieux de jacques chirac à
angela merkel à moins de deux semaines
de son départ il a effectué son dernier
voyage officiel en allemagne à l'elysée
bernadette chirac confie sa mélancolie
de quitter les lieux
enfin une foule imposante a assisté aux
obsèques de grégory lemarchal à chambéry
le jeune chanteur décédé des suites
d'une mucoviscidose a ensuite été
inhumée dans le village familial
pas de répit donc dans la campagne
présidentielle le débat était vif et
musclée hier soir il s'est achevée peu
avant minuit mais dès ce matin la
campagne a repris sur les chapeaux de
roue ségolène royal estime avoir marqué
des points elle était en déplacement
dans le nord avant de tenir ce soir un
meeting à lille sur place alexandre kara
zidène berkous quitte la journée elle a
reçu des appels pour la féliciter de son
débat mais imperturbable ségolène royal
replonge les mains dans la campagne
visite du sinn dans le nord et main
tendue à françois bayrou qui a annoncé
qu'il ne voterait pas pour nicolas
sarkozy si je suis élu je travaillerai
avec le centre
en général avec 20 juillet sur le
dernier grand meeting de la campagne
vingt mille personnes sont attendues ce
soir à lille sur fond de drapeau bleu
blanc rouge
l'heure est à la pelle ou centristes
alors si pierre mauroy et martine aubry
sont là c'est vers jacques delors que
tous les regards se tournent
l'ouverture politique n'est pas une
ouverture politicienne d'un meeting en
forme de bilan
ségolène royal remercie son équipe ses
soutiens ses électeurs du premier tour
et appelle une nouvelle fois à la
mobilisation
il est urgent d'inventer une france 9
une france protectrice une france
dynamique une france fraternelle et une
france conquérante
c'est à cela que je veux vous conduire
trois jours encore pour convaincre pour
tenter de faire mentir les sondages
ségolène royal espère séduire le centre
et pour cela elle jette toutes ses
forces dans la bataille
bonsoir dias butin baer vous êtes en
direct de lille où ségolène royal est en
train d'achever son discours elles
trouvent de nouvelles raisons d'y croire
vous tapez j'ajoute tout d'abord la
liste des personnalités dominique
strauss kahn et le chanteur renaud qui
sont présents ce soir à lille
effectivement dans ce sprint final il ya
une constante c'est l'offensive maximale
contre nicolas sarkozy
j'en veux pour preuve le discours de
jacques delors quitte alors qu'on
parlait dans le sujet jacques delors que
l'on imagine cause est réservée dont il
s'était chesnais contre je le cite ceux
qui vont s'établir en suisse et qui sont
acclamés dans les meetings de la droite
suivez son regard
tout cela dans le prolongement donc du
duel d'hier où ségolène royal s'est
montrée très offensive
elle pense qu'elle ya marqué des points
qu'elle a marqué son autorité sa
conviction
ajoutez à cela le succès populaire qui
se confirme vingt mille personnes ce
soir au moins dans les meetings et
effectivement les partisans de ségolène
royal pense qu'ils vont inverser le
pronostic est peut-être gagner dimanche
merci jeff pas de pause non plus je vous
le disais pour nicolas sarkozy lui aussi
pense qu'il est sorti vainqueur de ce
débat pour son dernier grand meeting
avant le deuxième tour il est ce soir à
montpellier où ségolène royal l'avait
devancé le 22 avril sur place nicolas
chateauneuf jean-marc new look
c'est la toute dernière étape d'un long
marathon nicolas sarkozy salue sa garde
rapprochée
avant de monter à la tribune devant plus
de dix mille personnes ici à montpellier
pour prononcer un discours vantant les
mérites de la nation la france à cesser
pour moi de n'être qu unité pour devenir
presque une personne une personne qui
souffre une personne qui espère une
personne qui a des sentiments
une personne qui a des valeurs une
personne qui a une identité l'identité
nationale française cinq sens pour moi
au premier rang la présence très
remarquée de bernadette chirac
autour d'elle tous les poids lourds de
l'ump stratège de campagne porte parole
et puis il y a eric besson celui qui a
quitté avec pertes et fracas l'équipe de
campagne de ségolène royal et qui prend
la parole tout soutenir nicolas sarkozy
que je suis va dimanche voté pour
nicolas sarkozy
et depuis dix ans la foulée militants
veulent croire à la victoire et au
destin présidentiel de leur champion
quand on est de droite aujourd'hui c'est
plus une honte il faut le dire il faut
le crier très fort donc on avance dans
ce pays qu'on le change mais bon ces
militants nicolas sarkozy revient sur la
plupart de ces grands elle une sorte de
synthèse avant le scrutin de dimanche
bonsoir michaël darmon vous êtes en
direct de montpellier nicolas sarkozy
plutôt posé hier soir a donc retrouvé
ses accents de tribun m'écoutait nicolas
sarkozy vient à l'instant de terminer
son discours est ici à montpellier
et alors si hier face à ségolène royal
on a vu un nicolas sarkozy on dirait
parfois même un peu réservé et bien là
il à renouer complètement avec ses
accents de tribun et il a rappelé ici
qu'il était le candidat du peuple en
martelant l'idée d'identité nationale
qu'il avait déjà porté durant la
campagne du premier tour alors à
montpellier où vous l'avez dit nicolas
seube le ségolène royal est arrivée
devant nicolas sarkozy ou également le
vote front national du fort il a tenu a
dessiné le projet d'une france basée sur
un état fort sur une demande de
république juste
le sens le roi nicolas sarkozy s'il est
élu dimanche essaye de s'apprêter à
parler aux français qu'ils n'auraient
pas voté pour lui il veut prendre la
posture vraiment de celui qui a pris en
charge la scion à chaque paragraphe il
dit je dors je serai le président je
serais le président alors voilà il s'y
prépare manifestement il faudra quand
même tout le monde attend le verdict des
français dimanche
merci smic elle et on revient maintenant
sur ce débat qui a tenu ses promesses et
qui vous a passionné vous étiez très
nombreux à le suivre
le face à face s'est vite transformé en
duel et malgré quelques convergences ce
sont bien deux projets distincts qui ont
été proposées arnaud boutet chloé le
compte lorsqu'il arrive elle est déjà là
20h50 les deux candidats se présentent
souriant sur le plateau c'est encore le
calme avant l'affrontement un débat
historique attendu véritable duel projet
contre projet sur les questions
économiques et sociales nicolas sarkozy
et ségolène royal ont marqué leurs
divergences premier exemple les 35
heures
qu'est ce que vous allez modifier dans
les 35 heures pour qu'on comprenne bien
les partenaires sociaux en discuterons
et se mettront d'accord et discuteront
branche par branche et s'il n'y a pas
d'accord il n'y aura pas de nouvelle loi
les 35 heures n'ont pas créé d'emploi et
les 35 heures ont été responsables
d'autre chose de plus grave encore c'est
la rigueur salariale qui fait que nos
salaires sont trop bas
vous savez ce que les gens ont fait du
temps libéré après les 35 heures qui
d'ailleurs contrairement ce que vous
avez dit en créer plus d'un million
d'emplois
les gens se sont pour 70% d'entre eux
mieux occuper de leurs familles autre
désaccord marqué sept fois par une passe
d'armes
la fonction publique
d'abord je n'ai pas dit que je
remonterai le nombre de fonctionnaires
j'ai dit que je maintenais leur nombre
mais que je redéployaient le nombre de
fonctionnaires en les retirant là où il
n'était plus nécessaire au lieu de
recruter des douaniers je répare les
infirmières les non c'est pas possible
adam mais je suis une maman ce n'est pas
parce que la fonction publique
hospitalière s'est payé par un autre
budget que le budget est recruté à
plaisanter parce que vous pensez à sévir
et l'assurance maladie non posée par des
fouilles entre les collectivités
territoriales et l'état vous pouvez pas
redéployer entre l'état et l'assurance
maladie
vous voulez vous à accéder aux
responsabilités et bien moi je le
pourrai ah bon elle veut augmenter les
bas salaires lui préfère détaxer les
heures supplémentaires réduire le train
de vie de l'état
le nouveau thème nouvelles
confrontations les retraites les lois
fillon ça consistait à passer à 40
années dans un premier temps 41 dans un
deuxième temps de cotisation
les dés de françois fillon qui tue les
des justes et puisqu'on va vivre plus
longtemps
il faut cotiser plus longtemps pour
payer les retraites ça me semble assez
simple
non ça dépend de la pénibilité du
travail je suis désolé mais big bang il
ya un écart espérance de vie tels que je
viens de vrai nom c'est très injuste
après 2h42 débat tous les thèmes n'ont
pas été abordés et parmi les sujets
oubliés la défense nationale ou les
banlieues pour les prochaines élections
présidentielles
je crois qu'il faudrait se mettre
d'accord à l'avance pour qu'il y ait
deux rencontres deux débats comme dans
la plupart des démocraties en a deux au
minimum et ainsi on pourrait traiter
tous les sujets nicolas sarkozy a trouvé
son adversaire agressive mais estime sa
mission accomplie j'étais heureux de
chanter parce qu'accepter
votre qualité je n'ai pas eu de problème
particulier durant ce départ paris c'est
parce que oui c'est bien
secrets de fabrication
je crois déjà que l'écran six ans pour
comparer un certain nombre de choses ça
c'est important
dimanche soir l'ultime face à face se
fera cette fois dans les urnes au moment
du vote
et avant d'entendre les réactions on en
vient à ce qui a sans doute été les
changes le plus marquant de la soirée ce
coup de colère de ségolène royal sur la
question de la scolarisation des enfants
handicapés dans un instant on verra
quelle est la vérité des chiffres
d'abord retour sur ce moment le plus
tendu du débat - tous les enfants
handicapés mentaux étaient accueillis à
l'école maternelle dès lors que les
parents le demander alors laissez de
côté vos tribunaux les démarches des
parents qui en ont assez des gens de
leurs souffrances et d'avoir vu leurs
enfants ne pas pouvoir est inscrit au
lors des rentrées scolaires pendant
lesquelles vous étiez au gouvernement
laissez cela de côté parce que la façon
là dont vous venez faire de l'immoralité
politique par rapport à une politique
qui a été détruite à laquelle je tenais
particulièrement parce que je sais à
quel point cela soulager les parents
devant leurs enfants accueillis à
l'école et c'est vous qui avez cassé
cette politique là cet écart entre le
discours et des seins et les actes
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit d'enfants
handicapés n'est pas acceptable et je
suis très en colère et les parents et
les familles qui vivent et les parents
non julien lemay montant pas du tout
avenant sylvain guinaudie parce que
franchement non je me réveille je non je
ne calmerait pas je ne calmeront pages
il en a que les fous et non pas de
mépris mais c'est un joyau que le mépris
que je n'ai pas perdu mes nerfs je suis
en colère sous les chenilles de répondre
vous permettez et il ya des caisses elle
est très utile je ne sais pas pourquoi
madame royal s'énerve et je ne m'énerve
pas très juste que ça doit être quand
vous êtes énervé alors je ne suis jamais
énervé je lisais beaucoup de sang-froid
après bien écoutez vous venez de le
perdre à nancy n'ont justement pas
jeunesse en colère on ajuste madame
royal mensonge hausse employer le mot
immoral samo fort madame royal se permet
d'employer ce mot parce que j'ai dit que
je souhaitais que tous les enfants ayant
un handicap soient scolarisés au milieu
scolaire
entre guillemets normal madame royal a
qualifié mon propos de larme à l'oeil
sous entendant par là que la sincérité
des tec de son côté que de mon côté il
devrait y avoir que du mensonge c'est
même le terme qui l'employait c'est pas
une façon de respecter son concurrent ou
un autre candidat
voilà un coup de colère qui n'est pas
resté sans réaction aujourd'hui on va
l'entendre
alors qui a raison qui a tort les
emplois ont ils étaient supprimés y at
il moins d'enfants handicapés scolarisés
réponse avec françois beaudonnet et
dominique bonnet 24 heures après le
débat la polémique sur la scolarisation
des enfants handicapés ne cesse de
prendre de l'ampleur
14h aujourd'hui des ministres de
l'éducation et de la santé improvisent
une grande conférence de presse il
dévisse de ségolène royal des excuses
c'était un coup politique malone est
basée sur ce qu'il ya de plus sensible
pour celles et ceux qui ont apporté un
enfant handicapé
et oui moi je suis sincèrement en colère
parce qu'on a cherché à tromper les
français
une heure et demie plus tard au siège du
parti socialiste
autre conférence de presse en urgence et
autre version des faits je persiste et
je signe
il la qualité de l'accueil quand ils
sont accueillis ils ne sont pas toujours
des enfants handicapés n'est pas assurée
trop de bricolage pour l'amateurisme
trop de précarité
qui dit donc la vérité les sept mille
postes d'emploi jeunes ont-ils été
supprimée comme l'affirmé ségolène royal
oui mais ils ont été remplacés alors
c'est parce qu'ils sont souvent
précaires ont été je dirais plutôt
transformé ça a été transformée cahin
caha avec des périodes de latence mais
en fait ils ont changé de nom il
s'appelait autrefois emplois jeunes et
s'appelle aujourd'hui assistant de vie
scolaire
les associations de parents d'enfants
handicapés parle en effet d'un trou
d'air dans les moyens en 2002 à l'époque
du changement de gouvernement mais elle
salue également la loi raffarin de 2005
qui donne le droit à l'école pour tout
enfant handicapé y at-il donc moins
d'enfants handicapés scolarisés
aujourd'hui qu'il ya cinq ans non leur
nombre est passé de 89 milles à 160
milles mais à droite comme à gauche dans
tout le monde s'accorde pour dire que ce
n'est pas suffisant
l'autre échanges plutôt vif de la soirée
a porté sur le nucléaire
les deux candidats n'étaient pas
d'accord sur les chiffres et sur les
réalisations en cours là encore nous
avons voulu savoir où était la vérité
julien bobot le nucléaire au coeur du
débat
un domaine qui demande précision des
chiffres à ce petit jeu là chacun des
candidats pensée figée l'autre est ce
que vous confirmez le choix nucléaire
savez vous quelle est la part du
nucléaire dans la consommation
d'électricité en france
oui mais ce que vous le confirmer le jeu
voir quelle est cette part le clou nous
avons madame grâce au nucléaire
une indépendance sur l'électricité de
l'offre mise en culture de la moitié
défendez le nucléaire mais oui ignorait
la parole au clair à l'amendé que non
quand la moitié de notre électricité qui
est d'origine nucléaire dans 17 pour non
seulement qu en fait personne n'a raison
la part du nucléaire dans la production
française d'électricité est de 78%
le chiffre de 17 % avancé par ségolène
royal correspond à la part du nucléaire
dans la consommation finale d'énergie
c'est-à-dire celle qui prend en compte
aussi le gaz le pétrole le charbon une
fois transformées autre point de
discorde le p r
nouveaux types de réacteurs nucléaires
je suspends le père dès que je suis et
c'est à dire un suspendait les nouvelles
centrales c'est elle et vous prolonger
le père n'est pas une nouvelle licence
d'une centrale bien sûr v mais vous
mélangez le père est un proto niant le
père est le prototype de quelle
génération n'est pas pour te dis que
c'est la quatrième génération
non mais le troisième général de le
vendre à la finlande madame le il faut
que les français comprennent ce réacteur
pressurisé européen est un réacteur
nucléaire de troisième génération créé
pour renouveler le parc vieillissant des
centrales
le premier modèle du genre est
actuellement en construction en finlande
fin des travaux 2011 coup plus de 3
milliards d'euros
les spécialistes ne parle donc pas de
prototype mais bien d'une nouvelle
centrale nucléaire
d'ailleurs un ep air est également en
construction en france dans la manche à
flamanville point commun entre les deux
candidats promouvoir les énergies
renouvelables
mais à des degrés différents nicolas
sarkozy lui veut par exemple prendre en
compte l'impact des éoliennes sur le
paysage ségolène royal elle souhaite
multiplier les sources d'énergie propres
alors au total qui a gagné qui a perdu
et bien comme d'habitude on entend tout
et son contraire du côté des militants
la soirée des uns et des autres avec
alix bouilhaguet et toutes nos équipes
il est minuit comme promis ségolène
royal fait son entrée dans ce restaurant
le débat est terminé pour les militants
un vainqueur saint paul
et c'est sans surprise montré que c'est
une femme qui avait la rigueur qui était
humaine qui avait du charisme et surtout
j'ai fait ça sert elle est très utile je
me suis beaucoup les militants d'un côté
les dirigeants au siège du ps de l'aude
mais un même constat
elle a fait la démonstration d'une force
de caractère d'une force de conviction
et d'une force de proposition c'est elle
qui a été précisent au moins c'est qu'au
lieu autre visage concentré et autres
impressions sur les sources et royal a
été souvent agressive presque toujours
apprécié et parfois méprisant
nous sommes cette fois ci dans une
discothèque ici les spectateurs sont ump
chacun est dans son rôle
applaudissements pour les répliques de
nicolas sarkozy hu et pour celle de
ségolène royal à leur domicile de mal à
discuter que ça finalement
contrairement à l'image qu'on veut
bayrou ces militants là sont des
centristes mais aussi jeux de l'udf il
est temps pour eux de choisir leur camp
je ne voterai pas pour sarkozy mais je
ne sais pas s'il voterait comme
malheureusement le vote blanc n'est pas
reconnu en france
je resterai chez moi dimanche
beaucoup d'entre eux le choix restera
cornélien jusque dans l'isoloir
deux réactions politiques françois
bayrou justement vous disais tout à
l'heure indique dans le journal le monde
qu'il ne votera pas nicolas sarkozy
dimanche prochain sans pour autant
préciser s'il votera pour ségolène royal
quant à nicolas dupont aignan il appelle
je cite à faire barrage à la gauche
je vous le disais en titre vous avez été
20 millions en moyenne à suivre ce débat
et jusqu'à 23 millions à certains
moments c'est beaucoup plus qu'il ya
douze ans voyons comment la soirée a été
vécue au bugue en dordogne où nous
sommes installés depuis plusieurs
semaines reportage vincent fourcade eric
masi au bugue comme ailleurs c'est le
petit jeu du jour refaire le match
d'hier elle avait un petit peu plus
attaquées et lui il a répondu avec des
chiffres un petit peu plus précis que
les chiens ils ont présenté pas qu'on
les attendait pour elle plus offensive
est lui très très calme dont je pense
que c'était le jeu en fait un retour en
arrière il est 21h le débat commence
les deux finalistes parle rapidement
finances publiques et faire une leçon
d'économie et puis j'aimerais bien
qu'après la parole quand même on se
capte en beauté c'est moi la
responsabilité de mépris je voulais dire
c'est parti aujourd'hui comprend l etat
match entendu c'est un match et je crois
que ma les verts n'ont qu'une envie
repartir et être énervé calgary stampede
ajouté ce que vous souffrez que je
puisse faire une phrase devant l'écran
quatre couples d'amis
certains votent à gauche à droite ou au
centre une heure vient de s'écouler
chacun guette la petite phrase qui va
faire mouche
voilà c'est le deuxième il va y avoir un
chaos
la peine non plus de nous envoyer des
grands mots à la figure c'est un débat
de techniciens 23h30 le débat touche à
sa fin réaction à chaud
ils s'en sont très bien tirés même quand
y en a un qui se faisait attaquer
l'autre elle savait répondre et se
maîtriser
ça s'est bien passé il n'y a rien qui a
fait avancer le débat ce soir c'est à
dire que en s'attendait à un joli match
était un match nul plus un autre débat
politique s'est engagé à table cette
fois et entre amis il s'est achevé très
tard dans la nuit
dernier élément sur ce débat il a été
très suivi à l'étranger et bénéficié
aussi d'une large couverture renaud
bernard avec tous nos correspondants sur
tous les continents et dans toutes les
langues de pékin et washington
les télévisions ont retransmis la colère
de ségolène royal et l'agacement de
nicolas sarkozy l'envoyé spécial de la
télévision russe s'est invité dans le
salon d'une famille française à berlin
française expatriée allemand francophile
réunis comme au spectacle
je pense que madame royal a parlé comme
une politicienne
l'opposition donc
elle était elle n'était pas trop sérieux
qui suivent l'afrique une question
majeure à dakar la rédaction de ce
quotidien a hésité jusqu'au dernier
moment entre la coupe d'europe de
football et le débat ambiance détendue
avec des inquiétudes quand même sur
l'avenir des relations franco-africaines
quelle que soit la personne qui va être
élu président de la république en france
apporte forcément un changement pour
l'afrique pour le sénégal chaîne en
arabe et en anglais la puissante chaîne
d'information qatarie al jazeera retient
du débat les questions internationales
nos téléspectateurs l'iran l'afrique de
l'union européenne ce sont des questions
importantes pour les télévisions du
monde entier c'était hier soir un simple
entraînement dimanche les journalistes
étrangers seront qu'ils soient plus
nombreux et à trois jours de ce second
tour la politique continue ce soir sur
france 2 les candidats racontée par
leurs proches c'est au sommaire d'envoyé
spécial avec guilaine chenu et françoise
joly à partir de 20h50
pendant ce temps jacques chirac fait ses
adieux il effectué aujourd'hui son
dernier voyage officiel en allemagne
pour saluer en gala merkel bernadette
chirac elle confie qu'il lui faudra du
courage pour quitter l'elysée véronique
sainte olives avec richard boutry de la
chaîne kto dernière cérémonie de
décoration dernière effusions dernière
félicitations ce matin le président de
la république a remis pour la dernière
fois dans la salle des fêtes de l'élysée
médaille de la légion d'honneur et
médaille du mérite
bernadette chirac prend la pause près de
l'évêque de pontoise
mais elle est déjà un peu ailleurs je
m'arme de courage pour finir le
déménagement de l'elysée on vient de lui
donner un chapelet du pape
bernadette chirac a le coeur un peu
lourd j'ai la possibilité de le faire
j'en ai besoin comme aide beaucoup dans
la condition de mes tâches dans les
mamans quelquefois difficile changement
de décor cet après-midi à berlin à
l'invitation d'angela merkel jacques
chirac effectué son dernier déplacement
à l'étranger comme président de la
république
la chancelière et jacques chirac sont
sur le même registre de l'émotion
partagée et du tutoiement affectueux dif
l'amitié franco amant je suis si heureux
d'être ici aujourd'hui on ayant répondu
à ton invitation et je voudrais
simplement te dire du fond du coeur
toute mon estime toute ma reconnaissance
et toute mon affection
embrassades et double baisement jacques
chirac a su pendant 12 ans nouer des
relations personnelles avec tous les
grands de ce monde
il est décidé à les perpétuer après
l'elysée les obsèques de grégory
lemarchal à chambéry une cérémonie très
émouvante suivie par une foule imposante
la disparition du jeune chanteur atteint
de mucoviscidose a touché beaucoup de
monde sur place denis sébastien thiéry
simonet une avalanche de fleurs blanches
ils sont plus d'un millier de fans
restés à l'extérieur de l'église des
anonymes venus parfois de loin qui ont
tenu à assister aux obsèques de leur
idole
c'est important d'être là pour moi
aujourd'hui parce que ce qu'il le
méritait pas ce qui vous a donné tout ce
qu'il a pu à son public l'avait
tellement fort tellement de courage que
badou si maintenant il est là pour lui
ça fait une peine énorme de devoir
partir si vite quoi on aurait espéré
qu'il ait quelques années de plus à
l'intérieur la cathédrale est comblé
la cérémonie sobre évoquera le souvenir
du jeune homme à la voix d'ange grégory
lemarchal avait remporté la star academy
en 2004
un an plus tard succès de son premier
album trois cent mille exemplaires
à travers plusieurs de ses représentants
comme marc lavoine ou patrick fiori le
monde de la chanson lui rend aussi
hommage parce que j'opère quoi droit
juste nickel pas d' embrouille
on
or quoi de voir des aînés et des jeunes
amants corruption aussi aussi au top
quoi grégory lemarchal était atteint de
mucoviscidose une maladie génétique qui
touche 6000 personnes en france et dont
l'issue faute de greffe et
malheureusement fatal l'âge moyen des
décès était le sien ses 24 ans tous les
décès comprenons la même valeur le sien
symbole particulier des applaudissements
à la sortie de l'église la foule salue
le chanteur une dernière fois sa famille
la campagne pour une inhumation dans
l'intimité
les résultats officiels du bac 2006 ils
ont été rendus publics aujourd'hui et
affiche un taux de réussite record 80
2,1 pour cent toutes filières confondues
florence griffon des cris de joie après
les cris de révolte contre les cpe cette
génération aura réussi à faire reculer
un gouvernement et obtenir son bénéfice
le record est historique
le taux de réussite s'établit à 82,1 en
% soit 2 10 à 2 1 point de plus qu'en
c'est même mieux qu'en 1968 un résultat
définitif que le ministère vient de
publier il prend en compte les élèves
qui ont passé le rattrapage en septembre
le bas qui a le mieux marché le bac s
scientifique neuf élèves sur dix ont
obtenu alors qu'il est réputé difficile
les bacs professionnels et
technologiques sont également en hausse
77 3 % de réussite c'est de 0,7 point de
plus que l'année dernière
de là à dire que le diplôme a été donné
une chose est sûre 2006 c'était vraiment
l'année où il fallait passer son bac à
l'étranger d'abord une rencontre inédite
celle de condoleezza rice chef de la
diplomatie américaine avec son homologue
iranien manouchehr mottaki s'était à
sharm el sheikh en egypte en marge de la
conférence internationale sur l'irak la
rencontre était brève on ne sait pas
exactement ce qui s'est dit chacun sait
que téhéran joue un rôle actif dans ce
conflit irakien en israël ehud olmert
est toujours
fragilisée après les pressions de son
parti et de son gouvernement c'est la
rue qui demandent sa démission du poste
de premier ministre plusieurs mouvements
et appelé à ce grand rassemblement ce
soir
cent mille personnes défilent à tel aviv
l'ecosse va-t-elle basculer dans
l'indépendantisme un scrutin local est
en cours en grande-bretagne les écossais
votent pour renouveler leur parlement et
le parti national écossais le snp a fait
la course en tête dans les sondages
ils bénéficient d'un soutien de poids en
la personne de l'acteur sean connery le
premier james bond envoyés spéciaux
edimbourg maryse burgot dominique
marault tél c'est un rituel immuable
depuis le moyen-âge à 13 heures leucan
on raisonne sur la ville d'édimbourg un
rituel immuable dans une écosse en
pleine révolution une écosse prospère
tenté par l'indépendance le britannique
c'est un tampon sur mon passeport moi je
suis pour une éco dépend doute quitter
la monarchie britannique
une idée relayée par l'un des écossais
les plus célèbres
l'acteur sean connery il appelle
aujourd'hui via ce message télévisé sur
internet a voté pour les indépendants
car les gosses qui jouit déjà d'une
certaine autonomie élite aujourd'hui son
parlement régional
le parti indépendantiste en tête dans
les sondages rappelé est aujourd'hui par
téléphone à ses sympathisants d'aller
voter
ce financier sont installés en écosse
depuis 20 ans et tout acquis à cette
cause
je crois que effectivement après 300 ans
les avantages premier but pour les
corses à faire partie de la grande
bretagne avoir accès à l'empiré
britannique au marché l'empiré
britannique tout seul maintenant c'est
du passé c'est terminé l'ecosse jadis
industrielle et ouvrière a désormais une
économie moderne
beaucoup de ces grands patrons ne vois
donc plus aujourd'hui aucune raison
de rester dans le giron britannique nous
pensons que notre économie serait bien
plus performant si nous en contrôlions
nous mêmes tous les mécanismes si les
indépendantistes l'emportent ce soir ils
promettent un référendum sur
l'indépendance dont les prochaines
années envisagé que l'ecosse keats le
royaume uni n'est donc plus du tout
farfelues ce parlement régional flambant
neufs pourraient un jour devenir
l'assemblée nationale d'un pays
souverain
une image étonnante une image des
caprices de la météo après la vague de
chaleur revoici la neige la route du
mont ventoux était impraticable
aujourd'hui les températures ont chuté
de 10 degrés en quelques jours
la neige tombera encore demain au dessus
de 1800 mètres toutes les précisions
après ce journal avec laurent romejko
santé la pollution automobile atteint
les enfants jusque dans les salles de
classe et elle favorise l'asthme et les
allergies
on s'en doutait bien une vaste étude
menée dans six villes de france et
publié aujourd'hui le confirme josé
blanc la pierre vincent bouffartigue
fenêtre est ouverte
les cm2 planchent sur un exercice de
maths tandis qu'au fond de la classe des
capteurs mesurent l'air qu'ils respirent
les élèves au bout de quelques jours le
filtre et de temps du gris au noir
tout dépend de la pollution du quartier
et quand on vit en bordure de rocade est
source de pollution ne manquent pas avec
leurs conséquences elles les allergies
à l'intérieur vous trouverez à brûle et
après sa pique aux yeux la cité dont les
trois quarts de mes élèves proviennent
son voisin direct de cette voie express
et
et du métro de 10 ont amené à ne
respirez que ces terres là de plus ce
sont des enfants qui partent peu en
vacances
aujourd'hui une étude inserm confirme
l'impact de la pollution atmosphérique
sur les allergies pouvant entraîner 10%
d'asthme 20% de rhume des foins 25%
d'eczéma voire plus grave il n'y a pas
que les allergies et l'asthme qui
peuvent être mises en relation avec la
pollution atmosphérique urbaine mais
aussi les maladies cardiovasculaires et
d'autres pathologies dont le cancer
l'étude conduite dans plusieurs villes
de france montrent en effet que rien
n'arrête la pollution en rouge les
particules diesel mesurer à l'extérieur
en bleu dans les salles de cours un peu
comme si l'on faisait la place au beau
milieu d'une voie express
une image de football c'était l'autre
grand duel de la soirée d'hier soir et
ce sont les latins qui l'ont emporté
le milan ac s'est qualifié pour la
finale de la ligue des champions
victoire 3 0 face à manchester united 2
buts signés khakassie d'or et gilardino
à l'aller les italiens avaient été
battus
3 à 2 ils seront opposés à liverpool un
autre club anglais pour le titre pour
terminer le pari réussi de michel
polnareff
à 62 ans il effectuer son retour il ya
quelques mois avec une grande série de
concerts et bien ils sont tous complets
il a décidé de remonter sur scène d'en
ajouter à la liste
olive et les nougats et dominique bonnet
ont pu rencontrer le chanteur à rennes
voici le reportage dans la main droite
il tient son costume de scène dans
quelques secondes
michel polnareff va mettre fin
à 34 ans d'attentes et
c'est
musique
il s'est préparé pendant trois mois
insuffisant selon lui pour être fin prêt
il fallait vraiment une grosse de grosse
dose d'inconscience pour le faire mais
ça a payé et ça casse et vous ça passe
et ça s'est passé
il fait salle comble partout en france
depuis deux mois depuis le grand jour le
premier soir le premier concert le 2
mars à paris qui est un très mauvais
souvenir bizarrement du 2 mars je pense
est quelque chose qui était tellement
trop disons que j'aimerais ça me manque
j'ai dit enfin en arrivant j'ai pas
préparé des secours mais je dirais enfin
les filets michel soit est génial soit
ces cinglés j'étais comme dans un film
dans lequel je me voyais et je sentais
que le public avait le trac pour moi
c'était très touchant
e
suite
maintenant au lieu d'avoir la couche de
monter sur scène
si l'envié de monter sur scène et de
voir les gens partir heureux
plus de 20 chansons plus de deux heures
de concert le temps nécessaire pour
envoyer tout le monde où vous savez
un mot de la journée de la liberté de la
presse comme chaque année l'association
reporters sans frontières met en vente
un album de photos sans clichés de stars
au festival de cannes avec vous l'avez
aperçu monica bellucci en couverture
voici quelques unes de ces images
rappelons que 24 journalistes sont morts
dans l'exercice de leurs fonctions
depuis le mois de janvier 125 sont
actuellement en prison
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi la météo donc laurent
romejko point route valérie maurice
20h50 envoyé spécial guilaine chenu et
françoise joly très bonne soirée
tout
une erreur
ce